[Music]
bourbon whiskey is uniquely American the
US Congress officially recognized it as
a product distinct to the nation this
amber hue brew was first cooked up by
Scottish and Irish settlers in late
eighteenth-century Kentucky today
production continues there with the
approval of Congress the American
government regulates the making of
bourbon to keep this native spirit true
to tradition by law it must be made from
a grain mix that's at least 51% corn
distillers often use more for flavor
shakers sift out cobs or other foreign
material and the Colonel's head into a
grinder inside rollers crush the kernels
to release the flavor of the starch the
process leaves larger chunks of the corn
germ and husks once distilled these bits
will settle out in separate batches the
machine also grinds malted barley and
soft red winter wheat they cook the corn
and blend it with limestone rich iron
free Kentucky water they add the barley
winter wheat and a bit of mash from a
previous batch along with a special
yeast formulation the grain mash flows
into fermentation tanks made of cypress
wood
after eight to ten hours the yeast works
its magic and the mash becomes a
bubbling brew the bubbling is caused by
the release of carbon dioxide gas as the
grains sugars ferment and become alcohol
after three days it has fermented into a
thick liquid they call distillers beer
they pump it into a column still which
boils off the alcohol leaving water and
other substances behind the alcoholic
vapor rises up to be condensed into
liquid after distilling it a second time
the alcohol concentration rises to a
strong 130 proof it's clear with no
noticeable color at this stage they call
it white dog once water has been added
to dilute the whiskey to 110 proof an
employee takes a sample and sends it to
the lab there a technician places a test
tube of the alcohol into a gas
chromatograph tester
it vaporizes the alcohol and then
analyzes the flavor compounds and
alcohol strength with approval from the
lab they're ready to barrel the batch
they pump it out of storage tanks and
into new oak barrels that have been
purposely charred on the inside charring
carmelize --is naturally occurring wood
sugars to add sweetness to the alcohol
as it ages it will also turn the clear
alcohol and amber color once corked with
the walnut stopper the employee rolls
the barrel into a multi-tiered warehouse
here the Bourbon will age for many years
partway through they'll move the barrel
to another level of the building due to
temperature variations this will make
the product more consistent after six to
seven years they uncork the stopper and
insert steel tubes to draw in ambient
air
this causes the Bourbon to flow freely
when tipped and it gushes into a trough
the alcohol has ripened to a sweet
caramel colored brew
[Music]
after they add more water to make it 90
proof it's ready for bottling nozzles
fill the bottles with bourbon right to
the neck the bottles then circle over to
the cap applicators the applicators spin
metal caps
screwing them onto the bottles the
bottles then ride a carousel and a
device picks up and applies the labels a
brush smooth them to the bottles down
the line a two-person team retrieves the
bottles and dips the caps and hot wax
the wax quickly dries and solidifies to
give the Bourbon a better seal after
several years in the distillery this
Kentucky Bourbon has come of age and
that calls for a toast
[Music]